ja mehr als 7 Monate Krieg in der
Ukraine und wir wollen anfangen mit Welt
exklusiven Bildern nämlich die ersten
Bilder des deutschen flakpanzers Gepard
in der Ukraine wir spielen das einfach
mal hier ab wir sehen ja ein selfie
Video eines ukrainischen Soldaten zuerst
fällt dir eine sa8 vorbei und direkt
danach und hier sehen wir es der Gepard
und wir haben heute morgen ein Tweet
gesehen das neuen ukrainischen Botschaft
Botschafter von olexes Thema kayef der
gesagt hat willkommen wunderschöne
deutsche Katze so hat er das geschrieben
und dieser Gepard der ist da nicht aus
Spaß sondern wir haben schon letzten
Tagen gesehen hier sehen wir noch mal
mit seinen beiden großen Kanonen hier
vorne dran dass der dass die russische
Luftwaffe eine extrem großes Problem hat
im Osten der Ukraine dort dringend
ukrainische Truppen in die Region
donetts vor und die russische Luftwaffe
hat in den letzten Tagen versucht das zu
verhindern hat bis zu sechs Flugzeuge
übers Wochenende verloren vier am
Samstag und zwei am Sonntag mit anderen
Worten der Gepard ist jetzt da dieser
Flakpanzer der deutsche Panzer 30 Stück
davon wurden geliefert und scheint es
den Russen extrem schwer zu machen wir
sind auch keine Aufnahmen dass er auch
eingesetzt wurde direkt um zu feuern wir
sehen und da wie er wegfährt aber wir
wissen das allein seinen Radar sein 15
km umfassendes 360 Grad Radar im so gut
ist dass die die ukrainischen Soldaten
mit den schultergestützten
flugabwehrsystemen von Typ eckler und
vom Typ vom vom Typ
amerikanischen Typ dort eben gewarnt
sind und Sie wissen wer jetzt kommt und
sie wissen was sie machen sollen wir
haben weitere Bilder aus der Region die
Ukraine hält das alles sehr sehr geheim
aber wir sehen hier eine völlig
zerstörte russische Stellung hier zwei
Ural LKW jetzt hier zwei völlig
zerstörte also ein Jeep dann zwei völlig
zerstörte
BMP2 Schützenpanzer und weitere Jeeps
wir sehen also es gibt schwerste Kämpfe
in dieser Region wir gucken uns das
einmal auf der Karte an um zu sehen was
die Ukrainer dort Vorhaben
hier haben wir die Karte des Ostens der
Ukraine und wir wissen in der Region
rakiv haben die Ukraine große Region
zurückerobert und von rakiv aus
versuchen Sie jetzt weiter nach Osten
vorzudringen und die intensive die wir
sehen wo auch der Gepard gefilmt wurde
herrscht hier im Süden von
hakiv und im Norden von Donezk hier also
versuchen die Ukraine weiter
vorzudringen und eben Richtung Grenze
Richtung Region du hanstern vor
zugeschlagen wir wissen dass dort mehr
als 10 kleinere Orte in den letzten
Tagen von Ukraine befreit werden wurden
und es geht weiter die Stadt Liman eine
Großstadt dort wird weiter von großen
gehalten aber die russischen
Propagandisten die Blogger mit der Armee
haben große Panik dass diese Stadt in
den nächsten Tagen eingeschlossen wird
und die russische Armee dort dann in
einen Kessel Gerät aber auch Russland
schlägt zurück man muss das ganz klar
sagen wir haben Fotos bzw Bilder von
gestern aus Odessa und wir sehen hier
oben eine neue Shahid 136 also eine
Kamikaze Drohne des Irans Hunderte davon
hat Russland gekauft in den letzten
Wochen und setzt jetzt man muss es sagen
sehr effektiv an wir sehen jetzt hier
gleich den Einschlag in einem Hochhaus
und das ist nicht irgendein Hochhaus
sondern das ist das Hauptquartier das
sogenannten
South also der südliche Militärkommandos
der ukrainischen Armee das wurde gestern
getroffen und wir sehen auch ganz gut
dass es bereits raucht das heißt wir
haben bereits ein präzisen Shahid 136
Einschlag hier gesehen und trotzdem war
es den Ukrainern nicht möglich die
zweite Drohne abzuschießen das also sehr
kompliziert für sie offenbar wir haben
einige Abschlüsse schon gesehen aber das
sind sehr kleine Drohnen mit sehr wenig
sage ich mal Fläche um mit sehr wenig
Masse um sie anzupeilen eben mit
Flugabwehrraketen beispielsweise und
deshalb wir sehen uns noch uns noch
einmal an scheint es hier für die Russen
relativ einfach zu sein diese durch die
ukrainischen Flugabwehr durchzubringen
und eben in militärische Ziele auch
zielgenau rein zu fliegen wir haben
heute morgen gehört dass angeblich das
Koordinationszentrum dieser Drohnen auf
der Krim angegriffen wurde von
ukrainischen heimatraketen also von
amerikanischen Raketen und das dort
mittlerweile dieses Kontrollzentrum für
die Drohnen ausgeschaltet wurde ob das
klar ist ob das tatsächlich stimmt
müssen wir sehen zuletzt noch Bilder aus
Russland bzw aus von der russisch
kasachischen Grenze das hier Bilder die
die ein tatsächlich erschaudern lassen
dort versuchen russische Männer der
Mobilisierung zu entkommen und wir sehen
das einfach mal links und rechts sie
fährt ein ähm fährt ein Auto durch die
Schlange und wir sehen es sind
ausschließlich Männer die dort stehen
die warten alle wollen alle nach
Kasachstan rein links und rechts
ausschließlich Männer die mit ihren
Autos aus zentral Russland nach
Kasachstan wollen dort drüber wollen und
dass man tausende gestern und wir wissen
dass seit heute morgen die russische
kasachische Grenze geschlossen ist
kasachstan hat also auch gesagt das geht
nicht mehr wir kriegen hier Menschen die
möglicherweise dieser Türe sind kriegen
möglicherweise politisches Problem mit
Russland wir sehen also der Krieg der in
der Ukraine weiter tobt den die Ukraine
weiter gewinnt ist in Russland so
unbeliebt dass immer mehr Russen aus
ihrem Land flüchten
[Musik]